what up space fame goes in here from
anime output and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy chapter in the
one punch man story
you guys have been loving the one punch
man content so if you want to keep it
coming
you know what to do smash that like
button like for real serious punch it
and share this video with any heroes for
fun that you know if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one punch
man videos that's just how it works at
this point and while you wait for the
next chapter
and video to drop feel free to check out
my growing one punch man playlist where
you'll find videos about blast
about s-class heroes dragon and god
level monsters and more
link in the description and also thank
you guys so much this is the first video
i'm gonna be uploading since we hit
1 million subscribers so thank you all
that is amazing now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all
so when i published the last video some
people said in the comments that i was
behind
on the manga which was weird because i
covered the latest chapter that dropped
on this dot com but i looked it up and
it turns out this published only part of
the chapter and even the chapter after
that
is out so here i am with as far as i can
tell the latest
most up-to-date chapter and oh boy it is
a big one
as mentioned the title blast actually
appeared and it's huge because it's the
most detailed appearance that we've seen
of him so far so make sure to stay tuned
for that
but let's start where we left off in the
last video as a courtesy to the over 250
000 of you that watched that one
so tatsumaki was kicking butt and as i
mentioned during the last video i could
see another twist coming and in fact
in the very next panel tatsumaki starts
coughing blood
straight up implying that she has
reached her limit she's pushed her body
too hard
a lot harder than we've ever seen
saitama pushing himself that's for sure
although imagine if we eventually got
saitama pushed so much that he starts
coughing blood that would be so
crazy although chances are it won't
happen if the current tone of the show
keeps up
and that's fine we can enjoy saitama's
humor as we enjoy the other s-class
heroes pushing themselves beyond their
limits
fubuki is worried noticing that there's
a disruption in her sister's psychic
waves and tatsumaki herself wonders
if she used too much power at once and i
appreciate this fight because it's not a
walk in the park for tatsumaki
despite how op she's always been she's
actually pushing herself here even if
she ends up winning
and that's significant in and of itself
monster psychos realizes that this is
her chance to escape
she creates a cloud of smoke and turns
into a monster airplane
and starts trying to get away as soon as
possible she wants to regroup
suck more blood from citizens regain
enough power to finish off a clearly not
100 tatsumaki tatumaki tries to sense
her but psychos is pretty clever here
she copies tatsumaki's move and splits
her energy in different directions
so tatsumaki can't tell which one is
really her psychos thinks that even
terrible tornado has
limits and that fortune is on her side
but just as it seems like fortunes are
turning in shonen manga that's when you
gotta be the most skeptical
despite what happened to tatsumaki she
exerts
even more power putting even more strain
on herself
i think at this point we can say she
surpassed her limits
i'm not talking about limit breakers
here but
this is post coughing up blood and she
manages to create
an unbelievably huge psychic barrier
so that psychos can't escape and that's
not all tatsumaki has
also set it up that the barrier is
doubly reinforced as both
sides are repelling now if psychos tries
to reverse the flow
she'll get stuck between the barrier
walls and i enjoy seeing the
complexities and strategies around
psychic powers since i usually don't
watch anime with psychics
so it's new and interesting stuff for me
and yes i know i totally have to catch
up on mob psycho 100.
psychos is ticked off and decides that
tatsumaki who seem to have already gone
beyond her limit can't possibly do
anything other than maintain
such a huge barrier and she shoots at
tatsumaki
it seems to spear her through the heart
but as the page turns
we realize that this was yet another
psychic dummy decoy
and tatsumaki just used it to identify
psychos location
and just then drive knight makes his way
to the scene he's not dead or in trouble
this very cool robot or cyborg we're
still not sure which
is in the house and ready to kick some
butt i really like drive knight the
number nine ranked as class hero
he defeated the dragon level monster
nyan as we see it's completely powerless
in drive night's monster container known
as the masher
any hero who can take out a dragon level
threat like that
is hype and things now definitely do not
look good for psychos who i made the
argument
could potentially be considered a god
level threat
since she's a threat to humanity but she
still hasn't been officially classified
as one
again bad guys in trouble always seem to
like talking about how they're superior
and this always happens we just talked
about how moro did it in dragon ball
super
and here psycho says she's the apex of
evolution
and drive knight shouldn't stand in her
way but he says in a james bond clever
comeback way
the essence of evolution is conflict and
that is the end of a chapter
however we will continue since we got
access to the next one as well
so in the cover of the next one
tatsumaki is looking calm and she says
i can keep this up forever implying that
the coughing of blood episode
is over and she can keep kicking butt no
problem she's truly terrifying when it
comes to her power
and you can see why she's a number two
s-class hero the more impressive she is
she also increases the hype for blast
who must be even stronger if he's number
one
we get a bit of a flashback for drive
knight just a five minute one
nothing too important happens in the
flashback drive knight wants a monster
sample of psychos
he borrows some energy to refuel and he
makes his way to tatsumaki and psychos
we however stop with handsomely masked
sweet mask
his opponent was extremely ugly fury
ugly in fact
and as a result all sweet masks could do
was close his eyes and curl up like a
baby he laments the fact that even
though he's so powerful
he still can't defeat ugliness a pretty
hilarious problem for a hero to have you
don't imagine that stopping batman or
superman
sweet mask was saved taken out like the
other s-class heroes by tatsumaki
and now he thinks all the s-class heroes
are looking down on him
and he is an a-class hero he's got a big
ego so he just wants them to feel envy
but then to drive the final nail in the
coffin
of his confidence child emperor tells
him that he doesn't seem in good shape
so he can stay in the rear guard and
take a break
imagine feeling the most shame you can
imagine for feeling weak
and then a kid comes along and is like
yeah we'll take care of the fighting
don't worry about it
you can imagine sweet mask is not
feeling good right now
sweet mask values appearances above all
else so this is the biggest nightmare
for him he fears that everyone heard his
conversation with tatsumaki when he was
begging for help and for someone to take
on his monster for him
at that point tatsumaki straight up said
that he shouldn't have come
down if he can't handle one monster like
that and she added that helping him
could cause the mission
fury ugly made sweet mask seem useless
and he wants to cover
up this disgrace so it won't tarnish his
position as an
idol hero he's so warped that he's
considering killing the s-class heroes
from behind at some point
when he gets the chance so they won't be
able to spread the word of how he acted
and then he plans to blame it on
monsters sweet mask in this sense is the
anti saitama saitama is a hero for fun
not too concerned with appearances
while sweet mask is just a hero for
position
and reputation and is willing to act
like a villain if it means
keeping that reputation safe but then
the hype moment happened sweet mask
it seems remembers a flashback to blast
and
if i'm not mistaken this is the most
detailed image of blast we got so far
his uniform is cool and his spiky hairdo
is too he tells sweet mask it'll be fine
now after he apparently killed a monster
saving him again the hype around blast
is so real
he seems to have saved so many people in
the past
that went on to become strong fighters
and he encouraged them
and had such a profound effect on them
and he even has blasts written on his
uniform so we can't mistake him for
someone else
very convenient and this memory along
with sweet masks slamming his head into
a rock
helps him snap out of his monstrous mood
and he appears to calm down
as the iron checks if he's okay sweet
mask says he almost forgot the
fundamentals of fashion
and that would be self-control he says
his outfit isn't matching that well
today
and ian asks if that's why he's in pain
such a hilarious
reason to be in pain by the way but as
webcomic readers know
there's more to the story than that but
i won't spoil it for manga onlys at this
point and that is it we should be
totally caught up with what's available
right now as far as the manga goes
sweet mask was looking very cool walking
onwards after remembering blast things
are really moving forward in the story
now
having read the webcomic i know we are
in for some epic fights
and now we got all the s-class heroes
regrouping including sweet mask
can't wait to see what happens next and
even as a webcomic reader i really enjoy
the manga because a lot more is added in
including many more details not to
mention the drawings are absolutely
beautiful
they really are let me know what you're
thinking about the one punch man manga
right now
drop any theories you have about blast
in the comments i'd like to make a video
on like some of the best theories so
that would be cool
bit by bit we are learning more about
him and if you want to you can check out
my blast video link in the description
if you want to see everything we know
about him so far
and that includes the webcomic info
which is much ahead of the manga
if you did enjoy this one punch man
video and want to see more one punch man
on this channel
make sure to smash that like button turn
it blue and share this video with any
heroes for fun that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe this
is crucial hit that notification bell
and select all or you will miss future
one punch man videos and as we wait for
the new chapters to drop feel free to
check out my growing one punch man
playlist where you'll find videos about
blast
about s-class heroes dragon and god
level monsters and more
link in the description and once again
thank you so much for 1 million
subscribers
it really is a dream come true and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who help make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patrons of legend the ones
acknowledged by
lord twigo himself alpha sigma and liam
thompson
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand on top all clans
in grata the world acquire respect but
they have a jonathan king rethuan day
aura
red-haired raven emperor otaku thomas
jones kin mono
admirath and christopher torley and are
pro hero to your patrons the one and
only gilgamesh who's the current most
donated overall champion
of the world nothing but a fan steelers
anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp joel stanton very gucci
jessica calefan
alicia actor hinokami and water bonnie
parks florian
joanne garcia mick sheamus deadly saint
and
high school dxd highschooldxd73 thank
you all so much
if you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron-only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime uproar link in the description if
you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed so yeah you
can support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you